[Music]
even the happiest superheroes involve a
few losses sometimes but which ones hit
us the hardest this year let's take a
look back at some of the most
devastating superhero deaths of 2021.
since paul bettany's vision suffered a
brutal death at thanos hands in 2018's
avengers infinity war there were as with
just about everything in one division
plenty of theories about how marvel's
favorite synthetic superhero was alive
in the show in the series's penultimate
episode it's finally confirmed that
shortly after viewing her lover's
disassembled body at sword headquarters
wanda used abilities she didn't even
know she had to create a dream vision
along with transforming the town of
westview and its inhabitants the vision
within the hex wanda created is borne
out of their shared connection with the
mind stone and over the course of the
series he slowly discovers that his wife
essentially created him out of pure
power
wanda finally admits this to him in the
series finale moments before she brings
down her mystical hex along with all the
illusions within it including vision oh
i
i read somewhere that's
it's bad luck to say goodbye in the dark
her lover seems hopeful that he will
find some way to return to her before he
fades into non-existence and who knows
sword's reassembled white vision is
still out there somewhere and he could
be the key to such a return along with
vision he and wanda's twin sons billy
and tommy also presumably fade away but
this isn't quite as certain as the dream
vision's death in a post-credits scene
as scarlet witch communes with the
darkhold we hear the boys calling out to
her for help perhaps pointing toward the
twins return in the upcoming doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
one of the impressive highlights of zack
snyder's justice league is the
opportunity to watch an expanded and
beautifully epic version of darkseid's
first effort to conquer earth in this
flashback we see a lot more of all the
combatants and in particular we see a
lot more of the green lantern who dies
fighting the super villain considering
who the green lantern is it's fitting he
should live and die in only a single
flashback scene the alien lantern is
jalen gur whose counterparts in the
source materials is introduced in 1991's
green lantern number 19. likewise in a
flashback that ends in his death in the
comics gur's story is a cautionary tale
about a lantern who's gifted with a ring
with no weaknesses and is killed by his
own overcompetence you could argue that
the movie jallenger dies from the same
thing since he falls going one-on-one
with darkseid but then again heading
straight for the big bad is kind of a
green lantern's job gur is knocked out
of the sky by parademons and darkseid
takes the opportunity to dominate his
foe killing him brutally guru's ring
leaves his dead finger and darkseid
reaches out to claim it but is
interrupted by the arrows of the greek
goddess artemis presumably the ring
flies away to find a new worthy green
lantern to secede ger
the falcon in the winter soldier has
been decidedly ambiguous regarding the
fate of steve rogers we still don't know
if he's dead retired in secrets or
somewhere else entirely but we know of
at least one hero who doesn't survive
the series in episode 4 lamar hoskins
aka battle star sacrifices himself to
save john walker from the flagsmashers
in the episode the head of the
flagsmasher's carly morgenthau is
finding sam's offer of assistance
tempting but she can't decide whether or
not to trust him she sets up a meeting
with sam wilson assuming that sam won't
hold up his part of the deal to come
alone john walker the new captain
america crashes the party and in the
ensuing battle one of carly's men gets a
hold of him while carly charges him with
a knife drawing lamar intercepts carly
tackling her to the floor in rage the
flag smasher leader hits lamar with all
of her enhanced strength sending him
flying backward into a pillar and
killing him instantly battlestar was
john walker's best friend and his
biggest cheerleader his death pushes the
already unstable walker over the edge
and at the end of the episode the new
captain america murders one of the flag
smashers in a very public and brutal
fashion
episode 5 opens with sam and bucky
clashing with walker to take back his
bloody shield and before long walker has
returned to the states where the title
of captain america is stripped from him
but of course he gets a new identity
before the show ends we're not going to
need a captain america
[Music]
we're going to need
a u.s agent
amazon prime unveiled its new original
animated series invincible at the end of
march and the premiere ends in a way
that lets you know that while this isn't
the boys it also definitely isn't super
friends early in the first episode we
meet the guardians of the globe the
series is version of dc's justice league
comprised of obvious stand-ins instead
of aquaman there's the fish headed
aquarius instead of the flash there's
red rush there's dark wing instead of
batman and so on and so on we meet them
as they're battling the formidable
mauler twins in washington dc who they
defeat only with the timely arrival of
omniman the show's answer to superman
and the father of the series his title
character in spite of what it first
appears to be a strong friendship
between omniman and the guardians the
episode ends with omniman luring the
other heroes into a secret meeting and
brutally murdering them all one by one
aquarius red rush darkwing the immortal
martian man green ghost and war woman
are all dead before the scene ends with
omni man not even bothering to give his
victims any explanation in the season
one finale omniman finally admits to his
son invincible that he murdered the
guardians because as it turns out he's
not on earth to protect it instead he's
here to prepare the planet to be
conquered by the interstellar viltrumide
empire
in a post-credits scene for the nexus
event episode 4 of loki we meet a
quartet of loki variants including the
figure dubbed classic loki played by
richard e grant this loki's outfit is
the most comic book accurate we've seen
so far in terms of the god's old school
look sadly the older loki doesn't
survive to see the credits of the
following episode when silvi devises a
plan to enchant the cloud beast eliath
in order to reach the mystery villain
behind the time variants authority
classic loki initially seems to want no
part of it but once a plant is hatched
and seems to be falling apart classic
loki appears to pitch in having spent
years perfecting his magic classic loki
is able to create the massive illusion
of a fully formed asgard classic loki's
illusion does its job and distracts
goliath long enough for sylvia and the
younger loki to regroup and eventually
enchant elias but before that happens
classic loki falls elia figures out the
deception and turns on the creator of
the false asgard just before he's
devoured classic loki screams at the
beast
his horned helmet crashes to the ground
where he stood only moments before
one of the first squad members to fall
in the suicide squad and the first who
also appears in the 2016 predecessor is
jai courtney's captain boomerang along
with harley quinn boomerang is one of
the first to fight back against a
platoon of corto maltese soldiers after
they opened fire we see one of his
glowing boomerangs kill a number of the
troops but unfortunately it's another
squad member's bungle that means the end
for the projectile slinging aussie when
mongal tries to take down the enemy
helicopter on her own it ultimately
works but it does more harm to task
force x than good as the chopper
struggles to ride itself the blades rip
through the nearby jungle captain
boomerang is impaled by multiple large
splinters from the devastated trees and
falls to his knees
seeing he's in trouble harley calls out
to her comrade from cover in his final
moments captain boomerang smiles at
harley until the fiery helicopter races
toward him and rips him to pieces
whether it's intentional or not it seems
like when it comes to veterans of 2016's
suicide squad their violent ends tend to
come directly or otherwise at the hands
of their teammates though he doesn't
seem to enjoy it very much peacemaker is
responsible for the death of the squad's
original movie field leader rick flack
when the thinker proves the rick flag
that the united states government not
only already knew about starro but is
actually responsible for bringing the
creature to earth and funding
experiments on it flag vows to expose
the conspiracy with a computer drive
containing all the relevant data but
after retrieving the drive flag finds
himself threatened by peacemaker we
learn was secretly tasked by amanda
waller to make sure the records don't
leave jotunheim a brutal fight ensues
between flag and peacemaker and flag
doesn't survive throughout the battle
while peacemaker refuses to relent it's
clear he's conflicted about what he's
doing flag temporarily gains the upper
hand pinning peacemaker to the ground
and choking him but peacemaker grabs a
nearby broken shard of porcelain and
drives it through flag's chest and into
his heart the colonel's last words are
peacemaker
[Music]
what a joke
if mongal is the most nerfed dc comics
character in the suicide squad david
dussmalchen's polkadot man super
power-wise at least if not in terms of
mental stability gets perhaps one of the
biggest boosts unlike his comic book
counterparts whose dot projectiles
spring from high-tech suit this version
of abner krill suffers an
interdimensional virus that will eat him
alive if he doesn't release the deadly
polka dots from his body at least twice
per day and while yes he looks like a
walking twister mat his dots are quite
deadly and he manages to [ __ ] the
massive star all on his own in the final
climactic battle sadly polkadot man
doesn't hurt the alien beast quite
enough to survive bloodsport lures
polkadot man out of hiding by telling
him starro is his mother when he takes a
look abner sees as he usually does his
mother in place of the giant alien he
lets loose his polka dots damaging one
of staro's limbs enough that all of the
aliens thrall scream out in unison but
right after polka dot man triumphantly
yells out that he's a superhero his
celebration is cut short as one of
star's limbs crushes him
the 2021 dc comics maxi series infinite
frontier packed plenty of big
developments into its pages including
the grisly deaths of some of the most
powerful characters to ever appear in
the dc universe throughout 2021's
infinite frontier number zero
interspersed with moments from across
the dc universe we get scenes of the
beans known as the quintessence speaking
with wonder woman and attempting to
recruit her to their ranks the
quintessence is a reality manipulating
council of what can only be described as
gods there's high father of the new gods
gandhith of owa's guardians of the
universe the phantom stranger the
spectre the goddess hera and the wizard
shazam thankfully wonder woman
ultimately turns down their offer of
membership because otherwise she'd
probably be dead right now toward the
end of the issue the terrifying super
villain dark side emerges reconstituted
from other versions of himself from
across the multiverse dark side is more
powerful than ever and easily murders
all six members of the quintessence
impaling them with dark energy and
stomping on their corpses
at the end of 2021's green lantern
number two the central power battery on
oa explodes along with all the people
killed in the explosion the destruction
of the battery leaves most of the green
lantern core defenseless almost every
single green lantern ring loses its
power after the death of the battery
leaving many lanterns missing others
caught in the void of space without
their ring to protect them and still
more as prey for the enemies of owa
who've long been waiting for such an
opportunity in green lantern number four
we begin to get a more complete list of
living lanterns dead ones and the
missing while a few names of the dead
are of core members never seen before in
the comics more than you might expect or
familiar characters in particular on owa
joe mullen receives word that aurecia
robb and isomoth cole who we saw
floating in space in the previous issue
are confirmed dead meanwhile lantern jon
stewart learns that a group of slavers
has killed and collected bounties on 300
members of the corps he has the slaver's
computers read the names of the dead
lanterns and there are at least five
who've appeared in previous comics the
stony stoney-skinned ash-pak glyph moro
palaqua bathsaarn of ron and the aquatic
not keloi
the heroes of titans lost donna troy in
the season 2 finale but it doesn't take
them quite as long to lose another one
of their members in season 3. in the
third episode of the third season hank
and dove hawk becomes a victim of jason
todd aka the red hood hawk allows jason
to lure him into a trap where he's
knocked out and wakes up with an
explosive device surgically implanted in
his chest
jason comes up with a cruel ruse for the
titans he tells him that the only way
he'll deactivate the explosive is if
they steal a shipment of gold bars for
him while superboy tries to use a
combination of his super speed and the
intellect gifted to him by lex luthor to
stop the bomb dove not willing to lose
hawk does jason's bidding after dove
delivers the gold to jason the villain
has one more trick up his sleeve he
gives dov a gun and tells her the
explosives deactivator has a dead man
switch if she kills jason hawk will be
saved nightwing arrives and tries to
stop dub but she pulls the trigger
unfortunately the gun's trigger proves
to be the explosives detonator moments
before superboy would have been able to
safely disarm the bomb it detonates
killing hawk
as soon as it was revealed that disney
plus what if would include an episode
inspired by the marvel zombies comic
stories it became one of the most highly
anticipated moments of the series while
what if zombies doesn't prove nearly as
graphic as the comic book that inspired
it the episode still has a pretty high
body count we find out that in this
reality when he went into the quantum
realm in search of his long-lost love
hank pym brings back a deadly zombie
virus soon after heroes like iron man
wong captain america wanda maximov
hawkeye and falcon are turned into
zombies by the time bruce banner arrives
on earth as far as the heroes are
concerned there's only a small band of
them left alive and uninfected by the
end of the episode most of the surviving
heroes are survivors no longer sharon
carter is killed by the zombie captain
america the wasp is infected during
combat and sacrifices herself bucky and
okoye are killed by the zombie wanda and
vision destroys himself by removing the
mind stone from his body the hulk
finally emerges from bruce banner to go
toe-to-toe with the zombie wanda and
it's implied that he makes the last
stand against maximoff in the zombie
hordes though we never see him fall the
only avengers on earth confirmed to
survive are spider-man black panther
ant-man's preserved head and if you can
count it dr strange's cloak of
levitation
in avengers number 46 the russian super
team the winter guard with the help of
the traitorous gorilla man invades
avengers mountain and kidnapped she-hulk
their justification for the assault is
to battle she-hulk wages with namor in
moscow in avengers 43 and 44 and the
resulting damage it causes in truth
though they want to bring jennifer
walters back to russia in order to
brainwash and transform her into their
puppet there's a major a mutant with the
ability to transform himself into the
form of a super strong bearer doesn't
survive the incursion though it isn't an
avenger who kills him having made a deal
with dracula and the winter guard
guerilla man sabotages the defenses of
avengers mountain and makes it easier
for the russian team to isolate she-hulk
and fight her on their own while
she-hulk almost manages to escape them
the artificial humanoid boss talk
ultimately subdues her as the team is on
their way out of the mountain ursa major
whispers to gorilla man indicating the
mutant apparently turned on his team and
tried to help the avengers in secret
when vostok yells to ursa made sure that
the team is leaving red widow responds
by noting that the bear is a traitor and
stabs ursa major through the neck
killing him
on the series premiere the hbo original
the never set in london at the end of
the 19th century we learn a mysterious
object flew over the city four years
before the events of the show the
objects scattered a glowing substance
over the populace granting some of them
superhuman abilities those with
abilities soon become known as the
touched feared by other londoners some
of the touch takes shelter in saint
romaldo's orphanage run by amalia true
forming a kind of superhero team in the
process one of the touched is mary
brighton whose ability is especially
interesting bright and seemingly alien
singing can only be heard by other
touched and upon hearing it they're
soothed in an effort to bring hope and
union to the touch inventor penance
creates an amplifier she hopes will
allow brighton's song to reach every
touchdown london hesitant at first
brighton eventually agrees to penance's
plan but mid-song she's abruptly riddled
with bullets by crews a criminal touched
with a gatling gun-like prosthetic arm
and the ability to fire bullets from his
body brighton dies almost instantly
robbing the touch to her gift
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you